[Music]
on this thursday night promising to make
housing more affordable
vying for votes with pledges that hit
close to home one million homes in the
next three years our focus is very
clearly on making sure people have homes
in their budget
calling the shots where the leaders and
voters stand on mandatory vaccinations
the danger as afghans desperately try to
escape the taliban
as the prime minister admits canada can
only do so much to get many people out
as many as we'd want
is going to be almost impossible and
high-tech wedding planning this is
amazing i wouldn't miss this baby the
surprise that had a canadian bridal
party beaming
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the most basic of issues
every canadian confronts the cost of
housing it is on the rise everywhere
whether you rent or are trying to buy
housing affordability is a key issue in
the federal election campaign soaring
home prices are squeezing many canadians
out of the market and lower income
families languish on waiting lists for
affordable housing according to the
canadian real estate association the
average sale price of a home in canada
jumped more than 15 percent in july
compared to last year the average cost
is now 662 thousand dollars the federal
parties all say they know housing is too
expensive and they have plans to fix it
in our top story tonight abigail beamon
looks at those promises
like many canadians affordable housing
is an issue for nicole farrow i do think
we need some stability in the property
market i mean everybody is concerned
about what's going to happen if interest
rates go up in the next five years
affordability has become such a problem
two major parties dropped plans to
tackle it in the first week of the
campaign
we have a housing crisis in canada we
will implement our plan to kick-start
the building of one million homes in the
next three years
conservatives say they'll reach that
goal in part by selling off and
transforming unused federal real estate
and by focusing on building homes close
to transit
sometimes in the past this hasn't been
at the center of the conservative
party's platform
the way that i think it needs to be for
the sake of all cities in canada
conservative plan is not going to create
homes that are within people's budgets
our focus is very clearly on making sure
people have homes in their budget new
democrats are promising to create half a
million affordable housing spaces in 10
years while the liberals haven't yet
announced their plan but have been
criticized for not building promised
affordable spaces fast enough
significant new investments in housing
that i'm looking forward to speaking
with
speaking about in the coming weeks all
three parties want to tackle foreign
home buyers driving up prices
conservatives want an outright ban for
two years the liberals promised a 1
annual tax in the last budget and the
ndp would slap on a one-time 20 percent
tax that one would make the most sense
20 i think would require more
consideration
for
you know a 1.5 million dollar house for
example
professor paul kershaw is calling for
policy changes that stop rising prices
potentially unpopular for voting
homeowners who like their increased
value that looks really great for me as
a homeowner but it is eroding the
affordability for those who walk in my
footsteps we need parties to acknowledge
it and right now none of the parties is
being that brave
chris shaw ad since none of the
platforms is costed we won't really know
which plan is most effective until we
learn the devil in the details donna all
right abigail aaron o'toole faced a lot
of questions about something else too in
the party platform it says we will
protect the conscience rights of health
care professionals there's no other
detail the party says its focus is on
doctors who don't want to perform
medical assistance in dying but it could
also include those who don't want to
refer patients for things like gender
reassignment surgery and abortion how is
o'toole handling questions about this
donna the abortion question comes up at
some point on every campaign and
certainly was an albatross around the
neck of o'toole's predecessor andrew
scheer o'toole very much trying to brand
himself as a new progressive type of
conservative leader and has stressed
multiple times on the trail that he is
pro-choice thursday he pushed back
against the idea that it's a
contradiction to be pro-choice and
support conscience rights saying there
can be a balance well i'm pro-choice and
i i want to make sure that access for
women to those services are available
across the country it's an important
right i will not only defend
i think we can also defend conscience
rights for
our incredible men and women on the
front lines in our health care system
but o'toole was not clear on the issue
of referrals under ontario law a doctor
refusing to provide an abortion must
provide a referral to another
practitioner so until he is more clear
on that point don't expect this issue to
disappear anytime soon donna all right
abigail beeman in ottawa thanks health
care is also top of mind for canadians
it was the focus of the ndp campaign
today leader jagmeet singh promises to
create a 250 million dollar fund to hire
and train two thousand nurses across
canada he made that announcement in
edmonton where the ndp is hoping to gain
some ground mike licature is there
after not even setting foot in alberta
for the 2019 election campaign jagmeet
singh strode into edmonton confident he
can gain seats in this province to do
that he waded into provincial
jurisdiction pledging to create a
quarter of a billion dollar fund
specifically to train and hire nurses a
move he says that would reverse years of
health care cuts
those cuts at the federal level from
justin trudeau and those cuts from jason
kenny are making it so it's so difficult
for these workers if you're keeping
score at home singh mentioned united
conservative premier jason kenny's name
seven times in his morning media
availability and federal conservative
leader erin o'toole
just once absolutely we're going to
point to jason kenney and his bad
decisions that hurt people we're going
to point to conservatives that can't be
trusted with health care a prime example
of how singh is hoping to parlay his
provincial party's popularity into
federal seats if you were to look at
polls now the ndp provincially would
sweep the province
but yet they have a problem federally
but jag jagmeet singh is more popular
now than he was two years ago but it's
not just a two-party race in edmonton
the liberals were shut out in 2019 but
are looking to take back two seats in
this city so it's not the ndp versus the
conservatives in edmonton it's the ndp
versus the liberals versus the
conservatives in edmonton but not all
provincial ndp support will flow to sing
he and rachel notley have not always
been on the same page especially when it
comes to pipelines or the oil and gas
industry her strategy has been to strike
a balance between energy and the
environment whereas judgment seeing is
focused much more on opposing things
like pipelines and specific projects
it's a really delicate dance for singh
so when he's asked about notley's
support he chose to focus on the issues
that they can agree on rather than the
ones that they don't
donna all right michael couture in
edmonton thank you now to the west coast
where the liberals made a big push today
for the senior vote justin trudeau says
if re-elected his government would
invest nine billion dollars to help
provinces and territories improve
long-term care that includes training up
to 50 000 new personal support workers
and providing all personal support
workers a minimum wage of at least 25
dollars an hour
our investments will allow us to create
more beds improve facilities and
increase infection prevention and
because provinces have different
realities we'll work together to make
sure that everyone gets the support they
need
it is day five of the campaign and both
justin trudeau and jagmeet singh have
spent two full days in british columbia
there is a good reason that province is
full of electoral races that any of the
three parties might win our chief
political correspondent david aiken
reports on the battle for b.c
welcome welcome to our video the liberal
leaders visit to this suburb east of
vancouver wednesday followed a visit
here tuesday by the ndp leader i'm
really excited to be here in port moody
kukulem
there's a good reason judgment sing and
justin trudeau were here in week one of
this election campaign this riding the
riding of port moody coquitlam was the
single closest race in the entire
country in 2019. conservative nelly shin
won by just 153 votes over the second
place new democrat the liberals finished
third about 1100 votes back this in a
riding where more than 54 000 people
voted but port moody coquitlam is just
one of more than a dozen ridings here in
bc that feature tight three-way races
for the liberals success in bc is
critical for their path back to majority
and trudeau is banking on his personal
connection to the province to win these
tight races i always talk about my bc
roots while they're particularly
poignant right here
because i have my my two aunts betsy two
of my aunts betsy and heather but polls
show many voters are looking favorably
on sings and ep and aaron o'toole's
conservatives must defend what they have
here if they have any hope of forming
government
bc is a tough place to call it's you
could
plausibly come up with any scenario that
sees any of the three main parties
capturing the most seats at the end of
this election but which party will
separate itself from the pack and how
well candidates on the ground here say
that the winning party has to make a
compelling case on two issues key to bc
voters first fighting climate change and
second finding a way to make housing
more affordable for middle class voters
donna all right david aiken in beautiful
victoria bc thanks another major
canadian jurisdiction is implementing
mandatory vaccines the city of toronto
says by october 30th all city workers
must be double dosed against covet 19
with a few exceptions the move to
mandate vaccines is picking up steam
across canada today ontario premier doug
ford kicked one of his mpps out of
caucus for refusing to get vaccinated
and late last week the liberals promised
to make vaccines mandatory for federal
workers and domestic travelers as eric
sorenson reports polling does show the
idea has broad public support
[Applause]
as a rule politicians don't like
hecklers but when groups tried to shout
down the liberal leader for mandating
vaccinations it was a scrap he seemed
happy to get into across the country
they're stepping up to get vaccinated
on the eve of the election call justin
trudeau declared vaccinations for
federal civil servants mandatory drawing
a distinction with the conservatives i
will respect
the personal health decisions of
canadians erin o'toole is pro-vaccine
but would not make them mandatory
trudeau left no wiggle room absent a
medical reason vaccines are a must for
civil servants or else there will be
consequences why come down so
unequivocally on this issue perhaps
because most voters have done so an
ipsos survey found 80 percent of
canadians support mandatory vaccinations
for federal public servants and for
teachers it's 81 percent and for health
care workers 84 percent of canadians
want vaccines to be mandatory and among
liberal voters all of these numbers are
above 90 percent even three-quarters of
conservative voters support mandatory
vaccinations most canadians also support
proof of vaccines for travel on trains
and planes and more than two-thirds back
vaccine passports to enter restaurants
gyms and other indoor venues there
really is no debate people think that
vaccines should be ubiquitous
and they think that should they should
be
directed
and even mandatory there's growing
urgency because the delta variant is
proving tenacious after dipping below
400 covid cases in mid-july there are
now more than 2 000 a day in this
country not as many as in the third wave
but the fourth wave is building it's
hoped mandatory vaccines will keep this
wave under control though it means some
will get vaccinated under duress says
this ethicist they will receive this and
they will not want it and they'll be
doing that to protect their livelihoods
it should also protect the health of
other canadians the city of toronto will
implement a mandatory requirement for
staff to be fully vaccinated more
governments at all levels are opting for
mandatory vaccines and while opponents
are vocal
there is broad public support for them
eric sorensen global news toronto
concerns about where polling stations
may be set up coming up should voters
mark their ballots inside schools plus
the race to rescue afghans the prime
minister admits it's not going to happen
fast
men and some women marching through
kabul today bravely waving the afghan
flag marking their country's
independence day and defying the taliban
who now control the country
thousands are still trying to escape on
flights pleading with canada and other
countries to take them in today prime
minister trudeau who has promised to
resettle more than 20 000 afghans
admitted it is easier said than done
it is going to be very very difficult to
get
many people out
we will get some certainly
but to get many people out as many as
we'd want
is going to be almost impossible in the
coming weeks
the u.s and nato forces now control the
airport and trudeau said again today
that canadian evacuation flights will
land soon but there is still no timeline
and as jackson proskow reports the clock
is ticking
the only way out is through kabul's
airport
where desperate scenes play out as
afghans and foreign citizens rush to the
gates
to get this far they must navigate
checkpoints and roadblocks manned by
taliban fighters
who sometimes fire shots into the air
and beat people back
the u.s has warned it cannot ensure safe
passage to the airport we maintain a
watchful eye and are continuously
conducting in-depth assessments to
protect the safety of americans hundreds
of additional u.s troops are on the
ground american war planes patrol above
around 2 000 people per day are now
leaving far below the u.s goal but still
an improvement
this fragile exit strategy is all there
is
blindsided by the rapid fall of
afghanistan the u.s is stuck in an
awkward truce with the taliban it is to
the advantage actually of the taliban
not to cross the united states on this
um because there are 5 000 american
troops there
if they wanted they could probably drive
the taliban out of kabul u.s president
joe biden has suggested american troops
may have to remain beyond a self-imposed
august 31st deadline
he remains unapologetic about the
disastrous american exits the idea that
somehow there's a way to have gotten out
without chaos ensuing i don't know how
that happens
already there are signs of turbulent
days ahead as some afghans push back
against taliban rule
it's that unknown future that's driving
thousands to flee while they still can
jackson prosko global news washington
despair and anger is growing in haiti
over the slow pace of aid reaching
earthquake victims there
crowds gathered outside an airport near
lake high to watch supplies be loaded
onto trucks aid is now trickling into
haiti but tens of thousands of people
still need help more than 2100 people
died in saturday's 7.2 earthquake and
there are still fears that number may
rise
where to put polling stations still
ahead the calls to keep them out of
schools
canadians head to the polls september
20th and though more mailing ballots
than ever are expected millions of
people will still go to polling stations
to mark their ballots in person often
those stations are set up inside schools
and this year elections canada is
running into some roadblocks jamie
morocco explains
should we both swing at the same time
winnipeg father of two brent johnson
doesn't mind the possibility of a
polling station at his son's school it's
been a challenging year and a half for
schools
and this i fear this could be one more
disruption but it's only one day but on
september 20th manitoba's premier says
schools in his province are off limits
to elections canada new brunswick has
also decided school facilities won't be
used as polling stations citing the risk
of covet exposure to unvaccinated kids
under 12. ontario's top doctor expressed
his concerns too additional people
coming into that
that venue may
be a risk to the public as first
reported by global news elections canada
won't be mandating its poll workers get
vaccinated instead it says it will focus
on masks physical distancing and
sanitizing there has not been outbreaks
of covid
as a result of in-person voting but only
nova scotia which just voted two days
ago has held an election during the
delta driven fourth wave the concern
with delta right now is that we know
that it is a variant that is much more
highly transmissible
than any of the other variants we've
seen before still the president of the
canadian teachers federation sam hammond
is confident if the health and safety
protocols are strictly followed it
doesn't view polling in schools as a
problem at this time
health experts say if we minimize indoor
interactions through mail-in ballots or
alternative settings perhaps polling
stations can be you know not in the
gymnasium they can be outdoors we can
exercise the essential right to vote
while keeping kids safe jamie morocco
global news toronto
beamed up next the wedding dream that
became a virtual reality
so many couples have postponed weddings
during the pandemic or downsized the
guest list others have found ingenious
ways to bring people together a groom in
ontario who knew his bride wanted her
best friend in england to be there found
a way to make her dream a virtual
reality redmond shannon has their story
all right do we have everybody jeff
gallant and his new wife brittany
finally tied the knot this month after
some pandemic disruptions we had planned
our wedding for may 29 2021 at the royal
york hotel downtown toronto ultimately
was last august i suppose
when britney had the foresight to change
it to
niagara on the lake that set the stage
for a perfect outdoor ceremony the only
thing missing one of the bridesmaids
stuck here in the uk due to pandemic
travel restrictions so with just a week
to go to the wedding jeff secretly
searched for a surprise solution
i just went on google and i typed in
top global
hologram or holographic companies and lo
and behold art media was at the top he
was very articulate and uh and i thought
would be great on camera and so we tried
i said hey no promises but we'll try to
make it happen in this schedule that
needed sarah the bridesmaid to go to the
company's london studio in the middle of
the night ready for the big reveal so
without further ado
i'd like to introduce you
to one of britney's bridesmaids from
london
sarah reddington
ring ring
london calling oh my god
she was more or less indistinguishable
from all the other bridesmaids like my
aunts as an example they felt that they
were on star trek like like literally it
was pretty trippy though i have to say
it felt like we were
in you know
in the future
a space-age way to cross an ocean we
still would have had an amazing wedding
nonetheless of course cherry on top but
but really it was the cherry on top art
media normally charges 25 000 for a
hologram broadcast but cut the couple a
special deal for their special day not a
bad wedding present redmond shannon
global news london
very nice and that is global national
for this thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's here canada is the big muddy
badlands in castle butte saskatchewan
we'd love to see your canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com or beam it in thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
you